les convienne sur ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui autour autour de touche pas
à mon poste en fin d'émission nous
devions recevoir jawad bendaoud que les
français connaissent depuis le 18
novembre 2015 puisqu'il a été celui qui
a hébergé à saint denis deux terroristes
ont participé au commando des terrasses
trois jours plus tôt à paris lui a
toujours affirmé que ce n'était pas le
cas mais la justice en a décidé
autrement puisqu'elle l'a condamné à
quatre ans de prison pour recel de
malfaiteurs terroristes il est sorti de
prison jawad est donc voulu on l'invité
ce soir pour qu'il revienne sur tout ce
qui s'est passé
c'était voilà ils voulaient voilà qui
s'exprime ce soir et c'est vrai que
voilà ça a énormément réagi là dessus et
sachez que si on l'avait invité ce soir
c'était bien sûr pas pour faire une
interview complaisante de jawad mais
c'était aussi on est énormément regardé
par des jeunes des jeunes qui parfois
savent plus trop où ils en sont et
qu'ils peuvent faire tout et n'importe
quoi et qui peuvent se retrouver dans
des situations inextricables et dans des
réseaux terroristes ou dans des réseaux
de malfaiteurs et je voulais le recevoir
ce soir justement comme je vous le dis
sans complaisance justement pour le
mettre face à ses responsabilités
et pour montrer et peut-être aux jeunes
qui nous regardent qu'il fallait pas
écouté tout et n'importe quoi et croire
tout ce qu'on peut vous dire et bien qu'
il ya des personnes qui sont extrêmement
mal intentionnés qui voit des jeunes en
détresse des jeunes qui n'ont pas
d'avenir les jeunes qui ne savent pas
quoi faire qui savent pas où aller et
qui les amène vers le mal parce qu'ils
aiment leur pays lors et leur font
croire que le mal peut leur rapporter
beaucoup d'argent et peut les sortir de
la galère c'est pour ça que je voulais
le recevoir ce soir et je voulais
montrer à tous les jeunes qui n'ont rien
de vous le savez on est le talk show de
numéro un sur les jeunes et je me suis
dit ce soir les jeunes je veux qu'ils
voient ça et je veux qu'ils comprennent
que c'est ça peut être dramatique
c'est un événement qui a marqué notre
vie et depuis cette date on ne vivra
plus jamais pareil tous si on n'ira plus
jamais un spectacle de la même façon on
marchera plus jamais dans la rue de la
même façon on fera jamais plus à des
terrasses de café de la même façon ça a
changé notre vie et
cette personne on appelle le logeur
les terroristes on a envie de savoir
quand il s'était retrouvé là pour pas
que ça arrive à d'autres gens peuvent
nous regarder et qui peuvent se
retrouver dans un réseau
extrêmement
mal faisons c'est pour ça qu'on venait
de recevoir j'ai pris la décision de
l'annuler
suite un tweet de bruyne est là
emmanuelli
elle m'écrit m'interpelle sur twitter
elle me dit jamais de ma vie je me
serais imaginez vous écrire pour
demander ça cyril hanouna 7 avec une
boule dans la gorge que je vous prie de
ne pas nous faire ça quand je parle de
nous ces deux noms de toutes les
victimes des attentats du 13 novembre
toutes les victimes
alors à la suite de ce tweet j'ai décidé
de ne pas le recevoir puisque pour moi
principaux concernés ce sont les
victimes et les familles des victimes
et donc j'ai pris la décision d'annuler
sa venue ce soir voilà et je pense avoir
pris la bonne décision puisque quand
j'ai lu le tweet de brunella emmanuelli
je me suis dit
si elle m'écrit ça c'est qu'il ya de
nombreuses victimes familles de victimes
qui n'ont pas envie de voir ça à la
télévision mais je voulais juste vous
expliquer ce soir pourquoi je voulais
recevoir jawad
parce que on peut être pris dans un
engrenage vous dit et ce soir je voulais
que tous les jeunes qui nous regardent
se disent je veux pas être comme lui je
veux pas être le prochain round c'est
pas l'avenir que je donc c'est pour ça
que je voulais le recevoir ce soir est
ce que vous avez quelque chose à dire
vaut autour de la table est ce que vous
comprenez cette décision parce que vous
pensez que j'ai pris la mauvaise
décision selon moi je respecte à 100% la
douleur des familles des victimes et
rien que pour ça je pense que vous avez
pris la bonne décision en revanche qui
m'énerve c'est la différence de
traitement entre bfm tv qui interviewait
assuré l'interné entre libération qui
lui a donné la parole également en 2019
était pmp je pense que tu es bmp ça fait
des années que c'est plus qu'une
émission de divertissement vous faites
de l'information sur et vous l'auriez
bien traités vous vous l'auriez mis face
à ses contradictions faisait à ses
erreurs et c'est pas parce qu'on
interview quelqu'un qu'on cautionne tout
ce qu'il est qu'on lui donne du crédit
je pense que c'est important à titre
informatif en revanche voit la suite à
ce tweet je pense que par respect c'est
bien ce que vous avez exactement mais
moi ce que je voulais montrer soit je
vous le dis on est quand même le média
le plus regardé par les jeunes par les
15 24 ans par les 15 34 ans donc
forcément je me suis dit on a un devoir
également
à ce que ces salles un salaire de
lanceurs d'alerté et c'est vrai que
voilà après je vous dis le tweet de 2,2
de cette jeune femme je me suis dit je
ne peux pas le faire ça aime le demande
et je respecte totalement donc j'ai dû
les widgets oui j'ai été j'ai chanté un
jour à à la prison de
fresnes au fresne exacto oui et jeux
pour les femmes et je me souviens un
jour je suis allé dans un des lieux où
les cellules les femmes aient été je dis
mais pourquoi tu es là elle me dit
j'étais au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment donc ces mots ça que je suis en
présent et c'est pour ça qu'on est en
droit c'est exactement ça il faut être
très vigilant où on va avec qui on sort
et caen qui ont ce qu'on dit ce n'est
pas aujourd'hui qu'on vous dit où tout
est ouvert toute là toute l'année et
cherchait qu un truc l'argent facile ça
c'est toujours bizarre de me croyez pas
voilà donc voilà donc j'ai pris la
décision de ne pas le recevoir